so if Romney was in the room right now
would you say hey Governor Romney hey
once you smoke a bowl well we could we
could tell them to do that you know it's
not too late you know if he wants a big
turn in the polls I think coming out for
legalization and and smoking a joint
would probably you know peel off a lot
of Obama supporters hi I'm Paul Dietrich
with reason TV and today we're talking
with Steve Chapman a longtime fixture of
the editorial page at the Chicago
Tribune he also has a column with
creators syndicate and writes for reason
calm Steve thanks for joining us nice to
be here the tribune company is it owns a
lot of media outlets but it's also going
through bankruptcy is this a time when
the mainstream media is puttering out
yeah I mean there are real problem is
advertising you know it used to be if
you wanted to if you wanted to find a
job you got a newspaper and looked at to
help on it you wanted to buy a car you
looked at the auto eyes want to buy a
house you looked at the real estate ads
and a lot of that was migrated to the
web and it's never coming back our task
is to figure out how we can generate ad
revenues online it's going to be it has
been a tough transition to a world where
we can make money off that the way we
used to as far as your professional
career goes where does this November
election stand regardless who wins
they're going to be things to write
about I'm confident of that whoever is
elected there will be enough things that
I don't like that I'll have no trouble
finding just to write about you recently
wrote in one of your columns that there
are three things that any young person
should know that they want to run for
president one day one of one of them is
to be from an Ivy League the other one
is to be a governor or senator and the
third one was to you have to smoke pot
why why do you have to smoke pot see I
you know it's a good question but when
we you know back in 92 we had a choice
between a guy who had smoked pot and a
guy who hadn't and we voted for the guy
who had and you know this year same
choice was this just sort of an
observation or was it sis or do you see
drug laws easing well I mean it's
partially just the law of averages there
were not a lot of people who grew up in
the last 40 years who didn't at least
try it Mitt Romney being one of the few
exceptions most people it doesn't bother
them at all it might actually help
Romney if he could say you know I did I
did try it and I did in
hail I think it would humanize him a
little bit and convince people that
maybe he's not as exotic as he sometimes
seems so if Romney was in the room right
now would you say hey Governor Romney
hey once you smoke a bowl well we could
we could tell them to do that you know
it's not too late you know if he wants a
big turn in the polls I think coming out
for legalization and and smoking a joint
would probably you know peel off a lot
of Obama supporters is that evidence of
America becoming more libertarian I
think America's gotten much more
libertarian in my lifetime when I was
growing up in Texas you get a life
sentence for marijuana possession
believe it or not there you know we've
had this war on drugs it's really i
think most people would say it's a
failure they're not sure they like the
alternative but they know what we're
doing is not working well it's not just
drugs it's also women have equal rights
gays aren't demonized anymore technology
is more accessible for people the world
is becoming more libertarian it's only
been I think about a decade since the
Supreme Court that the Supreme Court
said sodomy laws are unconstitutional
they're an invasion of privacy they're
not consistent with our constitutional
framework up until then there were
states that still you could go to jail
for committing gay sexual action or in
some cases even heterosexual acts of
sodomy your Texas transplant to Illinois
what's the biggest misconception about
the Midwest and Chicago America second
city what's the bit well I mean most
people think Chicago is cold and snowing
the winner is actually we have the same
climate as Los Angeles I you don't
believe that i don't believe i see
that's how stubborn this misconception
is I should come here in the winter and
you should that's the best time of year
could we go to the beach and play the
beach in the middle of January yeah yeah
I do it all the time are there any other
misconceptions about the Midwest that we
don't know about no I think most people
understand the mid business pretty well
i mean it's it's less glitzy than the
coast politically moderate than the
coast less prone to fads you know it's
just good solid salt of the earth but
that's what we are okay on that thank
you Steve for sitting down with us thank
you 4recent Evie I'm Paul Dietrich
you